after 29 visits to the show
we're now making it official
please welcome to the table
alyssa farah griffin
[Applause]
welcome to the club thank you i am so
excited it's i mean it's just an it's an
honor there's no other word for it this
show is iconic it is i mean it spent 25
seasons for a reason people it resonates
with people and what i was actually
really struck by because i've been kind
of reading up on who our viewers are and
trying to get a sense and i'm a long
time viewer it's not just what you think
it's i mean it's young women it's young
men it's older women it's older men it's
all over the map all over the
socioeconomic spectrum so i love that
about the table we represent like every
viewpoint imaginable plus it's fun
if anyone had ever told me i'd be
sitting at a table with whoopi goldberg
i would have said you are crazy it is
such an honor to be with you ladies
every day on this set is there one
co-host though that kind of intimidates
you a little bit so it's funny i came in
most afraid of joy but actually i think
um and you're not going to joyce she's
an icon yeah but the thing with joy is
she's so funny that when she does really
come after you she ends with humor right
which is the best um a cut that's kind
of like a tick exactly i'm like i can
deal with that
sonny is someone who i adore her because
she's brilliant she's prepared and like
you are not gonna get by just doing
talking points and thinking that she's
not going to come back at you with like
a whole list of receipts so they're
they've both been intimidating but
excellent to work with and i think iron
sharpens iron like they're
i'd rather be debating really smart
people because i think it makes me
better and more informed in my
viewpoints i'm here to just join this
table hopefully bring a different
perspective and i'm so excited for i'm
ready for it your viewpoint is a little
bit more on the conservative side so how
are you hoping that your point of view
will help folks you know the political
stances being uh laid out there on the
table at the roundtable i really want to
give a voice to the tens of millions of
americans who do lean right of center um
you know i've spoken out against the
former president but 70 million
americans voted for him and not many of
those people are patriotic decent
americans who just want something a
little different than what they're
saying in washington so i'm hoping i
could represent those americans a lot of
the middle of the country too that often
feels like their voices aren't heard um
and listen i'm confident in my positions
i've worked in republican politics for
longer than i'd like to admit so um it's
gonna get sporty it's gonna get feisty
but i also am someone who likes to
disagree respectfully i adore these
women so hopefully that comes across the
last couple of years have been a bit
turbulent for me i worked for an
administration that i ended up speaking
out against fervently and continued to
daily that changes a lot in your life i
lost a lot of friends i'm estranged from
family members what do you say to those
viewers that just because you are
formally associated with our former
president trump what do you say to those
people that have already made up their
mind about you
i would say take some time to get to
know me um i think all people are works
in progress but beyond that we can be
really reductive about how we look at
people in public life i think as they
see my heart they see my beliefs they
see the nuance behind what i'm fighting
for and advocating for they'll realize
that i think there's more we can find
common ground on than disagree and so
i'd say give me a chance wait and see i
think they're going to grow to
i'm sure many still disagree with me but
at least hopefully respect me if there's
one thing i believe it's that there's
more that unites this country than
divides it and i think that we can
demonstrate at this table what our
elected leaders often can't did you
reach out to any former co-hosts that
were more of the conservative side i did
i did i had a fabulous conversation
actually yesterday with elizabeth
hasselbach she was just a doll in a
dream i was a huge fan of hers i mean 10
years ago when she was on the show and
she was 25 when she started so i was
like girl i am proud of you because i
could not have done this at 25. and she
had great advice she said the team is
amazing lean on them lean on the women
invest in the relationships off-screen
and then you know bring the sport to the
table and you'll enjoy it so i really
appreciated that
[Music]
you